[Music]
all right guys have you ever heard of
a muk up day what what is it like
mukbang
no monk up day bunker muk update like
you mucked up
is it like opposite of makeup like you
make yourself look ugly day i like that
but no
oh what is it mock-up day and it's
australian slang so it's used for the
last day of school
before the annual examinations marked by
practical jokes and other student pranks
oh like senior prank kind of
yeah oh you mean mock-up day oh my god
it's mock-up day then i would annoy your
time yeah i can't do
accents no um but yeah so anyway why
can't you
oh nice thank you
i think you accented one word
but okay yeah so in australia there's
this one
school who's actually in trouble
because someone one of the students
they brought they really mocked it they
really mucked it up what do they do they
actually committed a crime
no that's always what happens but
allegedly
a student brought in a female sex doll
to the school oh [ __ ] and [ __ ] it in
front of everybody
no but several teachers including the
principal
[ __ ] it or seen sort of everybody
we're seen by many little kids like
primary school
age students as young as five with the
doll
during the school's 55 minute lunch
break
and they said that the taking turns on
it the blow up doll had visible
genitals and it was tied to a pull
during lunch break and had water and ice
thrown on it
and then uh they said that students and
at least one teacher rode on top of the
sex doll
down a children's slide and if even a
female name was given to the doll which
i don't know what the
name was [ __ ] that would have been my
guess yeah
it better have been the [ __ ] is a
female it's going to be offensive to
kids
sheila oh yeah that's a bad one sheila
sounds like well
sheila wait so all the kids saw was just
some naked doll a naked yeah with a
mouth going like this
they said that a young primary school
children they
they were describing so they told them
they never saw their mom naked
no so they said because i guess i didn't
know i was grossed out it happened today
at school dream book or whatever
and then a parent said that they were
august
and disgusted by the use of the sex cell
in front of young children and then
another one said that
a child told a teacher on that day that
they needed to
put put clothes on the doll oh that's
smart
why is there kids at this school it
sounded like a high school
so this school they have
students aged from from five to 18.
oh [ __ ] so but it was more for the 18
year old like their their graduation i
guess so yeah i don't know australians
have time for this though don't they
have like spiders as big as jeeps there
yeah like this isn't kangaroos that
could kick your ass yeah
this is a photo where the principal is
with the sex doll
she looks funny oh [ __ ] those are little
kids in the background yeah
like really little kids back here
they're all cracking up back there
yeah but i don't know it just looks like
a human balloon i mean definitely
inappropriate for sure especially
but it's a [ __ ] new york times parade
balloon like new york times square like
like the macy's they break genitals well
not with genitals
this one has genitals and also like the
[ __ ] lipstick with the circle
yeah like that typical sex doll look it
looks so super how do i explain to my
kid that the
this doll has a mouth like that yeah how
did the kid know what's gonna happen in
the mouth
yeah i don't know but the fact that they
understood enough like
that doll needs clothes yeah that's true
when i was a kid i always wanted a
barbie because i thought it was really
like sexual sexual to undress a barbie
and as a kid i was like that's seems
inappropriate i'm gonna do this by
myself mm-hmm you should just i never
have to your friend's house
how'd you get a barbie you have a
younger brother oh i don't have one i
never got a barbie but that was
something yeah
like that was their sister's barbie take
it off yeah i'll get you barbie
oh yeah could you yeah i remember
because i never liked playing with
barbies but i remember going to
a friend's house for a play date and she
had a [ __ ] ton of barbies
and i remember having the same thought
like we were changing their outfits and
i was like
oh my god ken what's going on where's
his den
[Laughter]
i remember like i was such a horny kid
too because i remember
like taking clothes off the barbie and
then like seeing her boobs and i'm like
wow she has boobs and then i was just
like
putting them together yeah you're making
them out of sex i don't even know what i
was doing
i don't even know this is natural in
your dna you just know this [ __ ]
just know all this [ __ ] so
sick me my friends will undress the
sisters barbies and then put them
naked in our pants and we walk around
play all day with them in their pants
they're just be inside so you just have
these barbie dolls sticking outside
and then we're just walking it would be
like in the dirt [ __ ] digging and
[ __ ]
they're like pokey i don't know man we
did some stupid [ __ ]
gi joes would invade my sister's [ __ ]
barbie castle
yeah and like or like her mansion or
whatever the [ __ ] and then we would
drag them out with their jeeps it was
pretty jarring when you think about it
like wow that was really like actually
like warlike
you guys were like sid from toy story
hmm yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
damn yeah but i can see why parents
would be upset
at this yeah uh a little blow up to all
around my five-year-old
i'd be a little upset yeah what was the
principal thinking yeah like the faculty
was okay
this is [ __ ] fun like high school is
one thing if it's if it's mock-up day
and it's high school you don't
understand but like a bunch of
five-year-olds
live a little it's mock-up day now
that's annoying knife
that's you know i call that a blow up
dog this is a blow up
that's a blow up though oh no
remember all those senior prank stuff
that they did on tv shows that were
hella legal but they were like totally
overlooking that like they would get the
principal's car and put it on top of the
high school
yeah i'm all like wait when you look
back it's like they have to
steal they have to break in steal this
[ __ ] car in the middle of the night
and then you got to get a crane break
into the school
put this car on the top and i was like
no one even addressed this in the show
that's crazy creative some people are
creative i remember at my high school
i forgot which teacher's car it was but
it was a volkswagen beetle
so i think like eight or ten kids got
all around it lifted it up and then just
all walked it to the pool and just
dropped it in there
what yeah that's a senior prank yeah
that's just vandalism that's just
vandalism just destroy someone's car are
you serious
that's intense that car's [ __ ] though
yeah yeah like like
what happens does the school cover that
the school board cover the
cost of recovering the car it wasn't
even look up day
no it's not my day at all wow
uh my school never really did any like
pranks you know i don't think anyone
really like gave a [ __ ] in my school
about about stuff like that yeah just
kind of like we just we just went
just kicked it they like released a lot
of goats on our field
i remember for the senior year i wasn't
it was rancho barona high school in in
san diego but
i wasn't part of it because i wasn't a
senior yet so that was when i was like a
sophomore and then basically after that
like you if you do this [ __ ] we will
suspend you expel you you will not walk
and like it was just like oh [ __ ] or i
can do anything no
it's [ __ ] up our field i only remember
our school participating in senior ditch
day
so like in uh oh but then our senior
ditch day sucked because we were
seven so it was like july 7 2007
oh summer time yeah it didn't even count
or i forgot i think we made up for it oh
i think they did april
3rd oh seven because then four plus
three equals seven what senior ditch day
i heard of that
but i ditched every day yeah yeah so it
wasn't special jeff apparently didn't
dis until they're in the supper
how do you ditch in them just like it's
senior ditch day and it's like you've
been in summer for a month
that's cute though no i think they ended
up doing april four
or april third because four plus three
equals seven yes yes that's what i said
is senior dish day when everyone just
decides to ditch for one day oh yeah so
you ditch on the day that you're the
your year
and the month and the day is like the
same your birthday
no of the the year that you're in like
your class of
blah blah blah so she was all seven that
was class about seven april third
yeah yeah so then april third was my day
like each day
senior
[Laughter]
if we graduated 2000 2002 2002
like january 1st then or something i was
at 04 i don't know
four or four i remember senior ditch day
me neither i've never heard of it oh
yeah we had that i just we were cool
every day and
when when i was 17 i said peace
because i i was able to sign myself out
of school
they're like are you sure you want to do
this and i'm like of course
i was waiting for this day dude i was so
jealous of those high schools that had
open lunches like open campus oh like
you would leave and come back
like we had that yeah i had that too i
know [ __ ] yeah i know why do we have
to have drive-by shootings and [ __ ]
it used to be like that my senior year i
had a i had enough like
credits or whatever i could i could
leave home i could leave
and go home i had like an early day i
remember those kids
so but then i was so bored at home i
would sneak back into school
and just go kick it with my drama
teacher in his class and just like chill
in a little theater because i didn't
have [ __ ] else to do so i'll just like
sneak back into school and just like
chill did you guys ever used to bribe
your teachers to buy you taco bell for
lunch
no no because i could drive there with
myself when i was a
uh senior [ __ ] damn dude you're one of
those too you had a car and everything
my parents uh got me a car and i paid
them back for it in three months
damn how are we making cars we're like a
thousand dollar
job i was working as a janitor [ __ ]
after school
and they're like ah [ __ ] losers
my car was 14 1400 bucks hiding formulas
on the mirror and [ __ ]
total beater car i i drove it was a
station wagon it was just a piece of
[ __ ]
can you still buy cars for like a
thousand bucks yeah use one just chill
yeah because my first car was like 1200
and that [ __ ] took me forever to save up
yeah mine was 2 000 i think
bro i remember i used to uh like sell
candy and bootleg cds to make money
right
and then um one day i was selling candy
during third period and [ __ ]
mr wolfe he was like he was like tim
you selling candy my class what what
what what club is this for and i was
like oh [ __ ] it wasn't for any clubs i
was like
uh drama right because i was cool with
mr carlin the drama teacher so he was
like yeah i'm sure mr crowley would love
to know that you're selling candy in my
class so he took him
he grabbed my back started eating it no
he just grabbed it he was like yeah you
can get this from mr carlin later that's
drama teacher
so [ __ ] after third period i ran to
mrs cronin
i told mr wolfe that i was stealing
candy for drama class okay for drama
club all right so
just just that he's going to bring you
my candy and carl's like all right so
that's it good period i go to mr carlin
i'm gonna get
he [ __ ] hands me a bag of money and
he's like yeah kids kept wanting to buy
your candy
so i was like so he [ __ ] was like
slang in my candy for me like
oh thanks for calling was sicker than i
even thought when you started the story
mr garland was the [ __ ] bro you died
last year [ __ ] recipes mr carlin
he sold your candy for you that's
amazing literally just handed me money
and i was like
bro oh thank you so cool you told them
how much you were selling it for
it was even everyone was like a dollar
yeah what a dope dude
imagine you were marking it up you lost
money are you pocketed like half of it
i wonder how much of that is like they
actually form alliances with the
other teachers or with the students you
know like when you look back
[Music]